you trousses d'un squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve sur ce deux traînage doha qui
vient tout juste de sortir en juillet
james est parti j'ai envie de faire un
petit jeu d'horreur aujourd'hui ça a
l'air d'être une aventure assez cool la
légende dit que le jeu se passe dans un
train j'ai absolument aucune idée de ce
qu'il faut faire de l'histoire de tous à
nos jours au secours découvrent tout en
osant ont bu une bière je veux je la
veux direct noyer ma peine dans l'alcool
et ses avances et j'avance j'avance dans
le train plutôt son bébé les portes sont
bloquées par une chaîne je peux la casse
et si je trouve quelque chose
effectivement il ya une belle petite
chaîne bien désagréable alors il faut
que je trouve quoi mais qu'au pire coûte
être foot est comme ça là je sens au
sein d'un seul bar pour se tenir mais
fait chier à iliad et stuff et d
instaurer dans la boîte bas voilà c'est
une pince assez bon voilà on l'a fait je
connais rien histoire en même temps le
résumé du jeu ne devait pas d'histoire
il disait dans un train ça dure une
heure et à deux résumé génial ah ben
voilà il ya eu des choses et c'est joli
ce wagon c'est le wagon enfants savez je
suis con la balle faire quoi boîte à
souvenirs eh oui monsieur oui j'ai
trouvé par man l'enfant est heureux il a
de la classe sous le soleil chaud de
l'été un cadeau présent sous l'arbre à
noël mais rien de tout ça ne peut
substituer l'amour d'un père et d'une
mère à je reviens la réalité qui est
beaucoup plus triste d'un coup le choc
lié à l'ombre d'un petit enfant oui il
ya des pleurs ou sa part en steak là je
préférais la petite maison dans la
prairie finalement je continue et ça ça
a bougé attention 3 de leur médium what
the anneaux qui sait puisque ça la voix
carbone photo où il assis à côté au lac
et al ouais c'est ta petite soeur là bas
au fond le très énervé ou c'est toi qui
est téléporté monsieur dans les deux cas
va être va te faire qu'est ce que vous
me voulez bonjour petit esprit mais
parlez moi la femme est faut qu'on
communique de chouettes option pas à la
fin 2010 - belge face à travers un jeu
bombay steak and ok tu étourdi très bien
je suis décidé à mon avis il faut que je
trouve un jouet pour la distraire
regardez elle veut la balle il ya un
dessin que l'ifo court trop la balle de
but capa touche pour couvrir [ __ ] ça
va me vanter cette touche shift l'
hôpital fêter je fais des dribbles c'est
pour toi alors oui rien de chasse un
truc cela il fallait apprendre
la première fait quoi disparaît
oui j'adore quand mes souhaits sont
exaucés comme ça et du coup je peux
passer et où la seule à jouer au ballon
à la caisse allait vite voilà allez hop
un mystère au monde je devrais rester
loin de ça là y'a pas des saints pour
indiquer comme avant un dessin pour les
nuls quoi ah bon de passer aux laquais
talent à cinématique abarth et petits
fantômes tas mais en fait c'est juste
l'un drôle et il m'a fait le petit coup
comme ça quoi ta mais j'ai peur que
jamais pourquoi je suis un des trois ans
avec des fantômes la guérilla ne rien
refuser à la guitare pour chanter ce
parfait eux-mêmes gratter pour faire des
notes alors il ya quoi faire la [ __ ]
ça me gonfle à la dengue à habas voilà
c'est la bible des portes c'est sûr va
demander qu'on fait je t'en conjure
ouvre toi
mais se passe rien voyez j'ai pas
compris d'où elles sortent bien mais une
clé à l'est où la porte au lac aux
mondiaux était passager là au nom si on
avait fait la connaissance de quelqu'un
il m'a flash blanc où suis-je dans la
même maison que tout à l'heure a cédé
russe monsieur voyez un mec bourré passé
en faisant le poirier ça normal ah bah
voilà ça s'ouvre ok donc là je m'enfuis
et je reviens dans le train et les
[ __ ] de chant enfin tous les sens
avec des gens je suis tellement heureux
comme ça va visage vide
le mec il a des glaires aux phoques
tout est devenu glauque mais cette scène
était si mignonne pour tous au nom me
fatiguer à chaque fois ya des vigiles
aux portes quoi oui bonjour le cauchemar
la fantaisie ne les regarde pas il
n'existe pas a oui mais j'ai pas trop le
choix de la voie qui m'a agacé par les
têtes volantes
je peux le prendre et ça mais laisse la
tête voleurs bas les suisses et des
beats volant il va te faire des snacks à
l'obligataire tout ça n'est que fantasy
tous année mais casse toi plus tard il
était au niveau de mon zizi là ça
devient glauque sérieux ou n'être que
fantaisie vous n'êtes que fantaisie à
temps et si je quitte des yeux à mais
c'est comme ça en fait que je dois pas
les voir le kiné je ferme les yeux et
puis voilà
oui j'ai joué des coudes mal dans ton
âme et du coup j'ai la masse alors là
mon gars avaient du coup j'ai un ancrage
fait je suis un crâne volant un an je
crois vous faites c'est la tête des deux
mais cela suffit que je leur rende leur
tête je te rends tu as tête
voilà du coup je dois retourner de la
touche shift aller ou pour courir
potager l'on prend la tête de l'autre
voilà bien cordialement poids je passais
maintenant il sait pousser pile de
manière à ce qu'on puisse faire est ce
qu'on puisse passer on a un petit flash
attention ou là le flash flou on vit
dans le métro on n'a plus de domicile
fixe à monde us m'agresser mais cela
laisse la boîte à relais cela à alive
leur m'agresser statu quo seth gueko par
sud dans un flash bon je viens de
cracher juste à nous revoilà c'est
génial
moi je suis vraiment très heureux j'ai
dû redémarrer la session cette fois ça
marche ils ont surtout en boitant plus
petit on avait raté le paradis de sa
abaissé la meuf qui se faisait agresser
là mais là il se paye tout agressé à
c'est plutôt avec la grèce le dancefloor
soul est ce que je veux dire ouais
ensuite elle rentre elle est souvent
retour on ferme à bso doit maintenant
lui rappeler aux outils de rentrer assez
le flash
alors pour le moment je n'arrive pas à
relier les boues à comprendre tout à
fait l'histoire mais ça va venir vous en
faites pas oulaï eu agression là vous
avez loin dead
là il ya un pistolet je le prends direct
mais sa part carrément sec land and gun
carrément mes mecs la touche shift
l'approché se traîne de en 2028 il ya la
touche shift pas touche shift pas de
vidéo de choix je viens de vider toutes
mes balles il gère 100 moines euros le
dire aux mondiaux la hache elle et pour
nous les pendules pour nous mon village
comme dans la halle prend h questions
cutting fantôme tire tire tire voulais
juste derrière elle voulait me tuer je
suis mort fin du jeu flash back et je me
retrouve dans le train là on en était
mais c'est formidable dommage je jouais
très joli très bien fait très poésie
voilà c'était l'instant compliments on
améliore flash back je suis avec un
footballeur au mollet je suis mec à on a
déjà tué et où on a déjà volé en fait
regarder les mannequins qui sont là qui
étaient dans le train mais tout est
relié à les bains prend les sacs voilà
on a volé sa caisse et là on part dans
notre caisse je suis mort il ya pas eu
un black je crois à ben voilà il faut
barricadé la porte aussi un sinon les
policiers arrivent ils font peu importe
je suis là ah bah voilà enfin il avance
mon dieu les policiers nous ont trouvés
on ne le tue pas il nous a rien fait
mach est sorti il avait bien 4 le
bellevue le policier roumain de voir
j'ai du mal à comprendre
whatsapp à sa part en prison plateau
bataclan bayrou ils veulent pas mais
c'est la loi il faut passer à autre
chose sûre est ce que je veux dire par
attac cette phrase ans a pas eu tous
allez vous en arreter [ __ ] de foire et
ashoka ou est-ce qu'on doit pas ramassé
un couteau pour couper les bras qui
dépasse tous avec illusion je fermais
les yeux et faire tout droit
ok je suis mort ce qu'on voit là je
pense que ça annonce la suite de
l'histoire en fait après le braquage on
a fini en prison
c'est comme les feux rouges en fait
voilà ce qui est des cas un bravo
mesdames gens n'aient pas à mes buts
messins truc non mais c'est chiant quoi
on est là on est là pour suivre une
histoire voilà vas-y mais je veux un
couteau pour couper tout le bras qui
dépasse à mes peines mes jeux et à ce qu
il a mimé la pression là à lui a l'air
un peu bizarre
aucun n'a réussi à voilà bah voilà ce
que j'avais dit on va en prison tu as à
ce stade il ya déjà un an de sa peine
qu'il a passée juste totalisant reste il
est de lui qu à la voilà au bout d'un an
il est enfin dans sa cellule
à eux deux ils retournent dans le trail
prince du 100 watts à toi je vais être
contre un boss là c'est quoi le délire
sa sauvegarde c'est une bonne nouvelle
ça à y réaliser des poches de
médicaments qui vont passer en
intraveineuse ça sur la maladie qu'on
attrape en prison ça c'est que tout est
de fumer aussi depuis début aurifère de
la fuite comment oses-tu qu'il attrape
pas une saloperie n'arrive là on regarde
en fait le train représente la vie du
mec je pense
et du coup dans différents wagons ces
différentes étapes de sa vie et là on
arrive dans le wagon qui représente sa
mort probablement regarder up flash même
mois la fumée dans le jeu nous fait
quelque chose
nous marchons à travers regardez ici un
cimetière c'est exactement ce que je
vous ai dit la hyène note en mode veille
à un flash au led retour des vieilles
petite note à côté de la tombe d'une
fille et là on retrouve dans ce dans ce
rer finalement plutôt user voire
maintien des fauteuils roulants on
avance et un autre aux flashbacks ont dû
alors là on est où on est au volant
nous voici donc j'ai décidé qui n'est
pas décédée ah je vois mon pote est
décédé il avait la tête dans tableau de
bord a en fait eu un taxi donc le
passage est mort apparemment parce que
la voiture prend feu il me semble voilà
donc j'essaie de le sauver tue pas sûr
que cela suffise
le mettre à plat ventre comme une
vieille merde contre le béton je suis
vraiment pas sûr que ça suffise la pls
position latérale de sécurité à la fin
de retour dans le métro il est où le
bonheur d'avant avec les petits ballons
les petits fantômes farges franchement
c'était bien d'être carrément de la
verdure qui sait et de l'eau même à sa
part en steaks
katia shadow en ressort de l'eau oh mon
dieu tout s'écroule en bon [ __ ] sa
part obstacles soit été par transformers
carrément aux mecs mais le saut était
normal soit faire nous a surpris c'est
le jeu est en 3d mon siège est relié au
je voyais
on est tombé dans le trou des abysses
nom n'apparaît sur nos routes alors pour
le moment je comprends absolument rien à
ce jeu au début j'avais une piste puis
elle s'est avérée être plus tard bassila
on est vieux la vieillesse je pense
seulement que le train a représenté la
vie du mec en fait non il va pas suicidé
le train arrive saute pas [ __ ]
pourquoi ses violons avec l'effet 3d est
relié au siège et donc l'homme est
décédé aux ultra trail simulateur 2015
eh ben c'est donc la fin du jeu [ __ ]
c'était un bon rejoint des biens
psychologique si vous n'avez rien
compris voici quelques explications
mais j'attends des explications comme
non je pense qu'en fait chaque wagon
représente une étape de la vie du mec et
au final le train de l'amener en enfer
on a vu doivent être c'est être un bilan
sur sa vie pour ensuite voir s'il va en
enfer ou ou je sais pas c'est une autre
forme fait mais peut-être par exemple on
le voit au début dans le métro il sauve
la femme qui se fait agresser
plus tard on voit qu'ils emboîtent avec
elle un peu plus tard et il fait un
braquage et finit en prison en sortant
de prison il va au cimetière et voit que
sa femme est morte
ensuite il est taxi et un accident et ça
tue le passager qui transportait et du
coup à la fin et se retrouve en enfer
pour toutes ces mauvaises actions qu'il
a fait et pourtant il est fait comme une
bonne action devait sauver la femme
d'une agression mais ça n'a pas suffi à
bazus voilà pour les explications
j'espère ça vous a plu en tout cas on
n'a pas l'habitude de faire des petits
jeux psychologiques comme ça où c'est
plus sérieux d'habitude mais j'aime bien
sa chance avec plaisir n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu aussi pour
se construit bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo ou dans une prochaine chanson jai
abonnés vers savoir garder le château
one piece